ثلاثة اثنان واحد
[موسيقى]
داخل هذا المختبر في جامعة فلوريدا الأطلسية يقوم
اثنان من أساتذة الهندسة
بمحاكاة السعال ليروا كيف
يمكن أن تنتشر قطرات فيروس كورونا في
مكان العمل ومواقف أخرى من العالم الحقيقي
تمتلئ فم عارضة أزياء هذا
بالماء وتجبر مضخة الجلسرين على
طرده  الخليط المشابه للسعال ، حيث
يلتقط الليزر الأخضر القطرات في
الهواء
[موسيقى
] لا يهتم الأساتذة كثيرًا
بالقطرات الكبيرة التي تسقط على الأرض ،
بل إن القطرات الصغيرة
التي تتطاير في الهواء هي التي تشكل
أكبر خطر
على  محاكاة العالم الحقيقي ، حيث
يستخدم الأساتذة شاشة زجاجية
مماثلة لتلك الموجودة داخل العديد من
متاجر البيع بالتجزئة وصالونات الأظافر
والمطارات في جميع أنحاء البلاد
عندما تسعل عارضة أزياء الشاشة
تحبس معظم الجسيمات الأكبر حجمًا ،
لذلك قد يتجنب الشخص الموجود على الجانب الآخر
إصابة مباشرة ولكن هؤلاء
لا تزال الجسيمات الصغيرة المتطايرة تتسرب من الجوانب
وفوق الجزء العلوي لا يسقط هذا
الممر بنسبة مائة بالمائة  من هذه القطرة إلى الجانب الآخر
لكنها تقلل
من العدد الذي تمر به من خلال
الأستاذ مانهارد دانيك يقول إن
الشاشات تقلل تركيز القطرة
بحوالي 80 في المائة وبالتالي يكون الحمل الفيروسي
أقل بكثير وقد لا يذهب تيار السعال
بعيدًا مع  الشاشة
عندما زرنا هذا المختبر في وقت سابق من
الوباء لاختبار قوة السعال
بدون زجاج شبكي قطيرات الشاشة تنتقل
لمسافة تصل إلى 12 قدمًا مع عدم وجود
شيء يوقفها ، ولكن حتى مع الشاشة ،
يمكن أن تتراكم قطرات الرذاذ المتطايرة
في الهواء التي يمكنني البقاء فيها
سبع ثمان دقائق وجد الأساتذة أن
الإخفاء يمكن أن يساعد في وقف الانتشار عند
استخدامه مع شاشة زجاج شبكي
ولكن يجب أن يكون قناعًا عالي الجودة عندما
جربنا قناعًا بسيطًا من القماش ، حدث هذا
ثلاث
قطرتين مررت معظم القطرات من
خلاله وأثناء الشاشات  يمكن أن يساعد في
حمايتك يقول الأستاذ دانيك إن الكثير
منهم في غرفة واحدة يمكن أن يمنع تدفق الهواء ويعرض
الأشخاص للخطر
الآن هذا النوع من الإعداد يحاكي
بيئة مكتبية  إنه مكتب زجاجي
بثلاثة جوانب ، وقد تجد
هذا أيضًا في الفصل الدراسي ، والسؤال هو ما إذا كان
شخص ما يسعل ، فهل سيوقف انتشاره ،
لذا دعنا نطفئ الأنوار
ونكتشف أن الشاشة ثلاثية الجوانب تساعد في احتواء
جزء كبير من القطرات الأكثر
دوامة  في الداخل ، لذا تعمل الشاشة أيضًا على
إبطاء قوة
نفاثة السعال ، نعم بالضبط أنه لا يزال
يحذر إذا كان الهواء في الغرفة يتدفق
نحو مصدر السعال ،
فقد يكون هناك تأثير خلفي في هذه
الحالة سيكون الفيروس المحاصر خلف
المكتب  دفعنا إلى الوراء أكثر نحو أولئك الذين
يجلسون خلف الشخص الذي سعل
مع إعداد مكتب مكان العمل ، جربنا
قناع n95 عالي الجودة لمعرفة ما إذا كان قد
ساعد القطرات على الارتفاع مباشرة
في الهواء من خلال الفجوة الصغيرة عند
جسر الأنف المقاوم للبئر-  القناع المجهز
هو أفضل القطرات
التي يتم دفعها للأمام على الرغم من أنها صحيحة
بحيث يظهر ذلك أنه في عام 95 أحدث
فرقًا ، نعم إنه يحدث
فرقًا.  دانيا بيتش
فلوريدا